النقابات هددت اليوم تفي بوعودها في
التصعيد الاقصى بوتيره الاضرابات هؤلاء
المضربون يبداون بمسيره من هذا المكان حتى
مقر الحكومه في شريط هؤلاء من بين نصف
مليون من العمال والموظفين الذين يضربون
عبر مختلف القطاعات ودوائر الحكوميه هنا
في بريطانيا يقولون ساعات عمل طويله
ورواتب بالكاد تكفي طبعا جعلت العديد منهم
عشرات الالاف يعتمدون على بنوك الطعام
بسبب عجلهم عن تحمل تكاليف المعيشه في
بريطانيا الحكومه ببساطه تقول ان لاما
لديها لتحقيق مطالبهم برفع الاجور تقول ان
الحلب عبر التفاوض وليس عبر الاضراب بل
انها تذهب يعني باتجاه تمرير مشروع قانون
وذلك للحد من تحركات النقابات العماليه
وحتى حل هذا الخلاف بين الحكومه والنقابات
ستواجه بريطانيا المزيد من اضرابات خلال
الاسابيع والاشهر القليله المقبله اليوم
اضراب موظفي الخدمه المدنيه والنقل
والمعلمين ولكن الاسبوع القادم سيكون
اضراب الاسعاف والممرضين ما يعني زياده
الضغط على النقابات او زياده الضغط على
قطاع الصحه في بريطانيا الذي يعاني
بالاساس من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه